Dance...
For sure, like, rough around the edges.
...ask  these old people.
[laughing]
♪ rock ♪
Here in Kyiv, Ukraine.
Where I currently live
and today we're going to go to
the most dangerous neighborhood in Kyiv
and I was just back in the US,
where I'm from
and when I told people,
strangers I didn't know
that I lived in Ukraine,
everyone uniformly said... everyone said,
"Isn't it dangerous there?"
And when I go to Europe,
especially Western Europe,
and I say I live in Ukraine, everyone says,
"Isn't it dangerous there?"
"Why would you be there?"
So I get it.
Ukraine isn't represented
very well in the world.
It's in political turmoil,
or war, or oligarchs,
or financial problems.
Whatever it is,
it's usually not positive news.
So I thought I'd show you guys
what the hood looks like in Kyiv.
Like, what's the bad side of the tracks?
'Cause every city has that, right?
Like, every city has a rough part.
There's a guy in the trash
but overall, this is a nice neighborhood.
Parks, families, cafes, leaves turning.
But what's the ghetto like?
And so when I think of
tough cities in the world,
I think of, like, Rio de Janeiro.
I think of Buenos Aires,
and if you walk into, say, those cities
with these, you know,
new white Adidas kicks
and a $350 GoPro in your hand
you really don't expect
to leave with those things.
I don't at least.
I wouldn't be doing it.
Today I'm gonna go in that way,
I'm going with my new kicks.
I'm going in with my expensive camera
and we're gonna see what it's really like.
So I did a survey with Ukrainians.
I asked, "Where is the rough neighborhood?"
"Where's the hood in Kyiv?"
And there's no...
There's no one definite place for that
because I got all sorts of answers
but the number one answer
was a place called Troieshchyna.
So we're gonna go to Troieshchyna.
Gotta say,
there's a lot of charm in this city.
Little businesses like that, archways...
[Ukrainian]
Nice people.
-[quietly] Thank you.
Yeah, very sweet.
Very cool city to live in
and then you have all this history.
You have some stuff's falling down,
but some stuff's absolutely beautiful,
different eclectic restaurants, businesses.
There's texture here.
It's all properly mixed up.
When I first moved here three and a half...
No, three years ago...
Uber hardly worked.
It was like 10 minutes for a ride.
Now, one minute.
[Ukrainian]
When life puts you in a crack,
you end up in Troieshchyna.
So they say.
♪ Ukrainian music on the radio ♪
[Ukrainian]
Made it.
[door closes]
Center of Troieshchyna.
Looks like your classic
Soviet administrative building.
Heavy, powerful.
The Gopnik, the drunks,
come out later at night.
but...
I mean, c'mon.
C'mon, I gotta find more than this.
This is a failure of a video
if this is the bad neighborhood.
Okay, let's go ask someone.
Let's go ask...
Those teens look a little pissed off.
Should I do it?
Yeah, let me try.
[Ukrainian]
So, observation of
Eastern Europe in general.
Everyone's smoking.
Not everyone,
but there's a lot of smoking going on.
But good vibe here,
that's the weird part.
This is quite a nice vibe
in this part of the city
[Power Wheels]
Let's ask these old people,
maybe they know.
[Power Wheels]
I asked, "Where's the dangerous
neighborhood in Kyiv?", right?
[all laughing]
And everyone says, "Troieshchyna."
Right?
-Yeah.
[all laughing]
And I'm here, and it's kids with balls,
families, you guys.
You're not too danger...
You're a little dangerous maybe.
[all laughing]
-Go in Donbas.
PETER: Donbas, Donbas.
Okay, she's saying going
where the conflict is, the war.
No, I don't wanna go there
but how about in Kyiv?
Is there any, like...
Is there any real sh*tty neighborhood?
Borshchahovka, okay.
...and we're gonna go to Borshchahovka,
'cause this is bullsh*t.
This is...
This is embarrassing for
dangerous neighborhoods in the world.
GIRL: You should go here at night.
-Yeah, maybe.
PETER: At night?
[skateboards clacking]
To be fair, night time...
I'm sure it's different.
I'm sure there's some
tough, tough edges to this part of the city
but to be 100% real,
it's like amateur hour for danger
if I'm gonna compare with
parts of San Francisco,
parts of Los Angeles,
definitely any Latin American city.
-What's this neighborhood?
-This neighborhood is...
Well, we're coming up
on the tenderloin neighborhood.
Do you like it?
-Yes, it's very beautiful.
-It's beautiful, okay.
Well, you'll notice another difference
coming up here soon.
It's a little bit of
an eclectic neighborhood, let's call it.
And that hill, right?
That hill was just like...
-Luxury straight in your face.
-Five minute ago.
Five minutes ago, right?
-No f*ckin' way, barbecue in the street?
-Yeah.
What are you guys cooking up here?
We're popping out of this soon,
don't worry.
I only did a little section of it for you.
[people chattering]
Okay, what is it?
15 minutes to get there.
Okay, let's see it.
I think it's gonna be
more promising than here.
Here we are, Borshchahivka.
I gotta get a Snickers bar
'cause I'm about to pass out.
Super hungry and this is it.
This is what I've heard
from all the kids in Troieshchyna.
It was actually the second place online
from Troieshchyna,
that it was the dangerous neighborhood.
So if it's gonna be somewhere, it's here.
I think we gotta go
into the apartment blocks.
That might be our ticket.
I think one of these
little courtyard zones.
Feels grittier for sure.
[man blowing his nose]
Rough around the edges for Kyiv.
Definitely this is not
the neighborhood I live in.
-We have two girls, she very dangerous.
-Let's go find 'em.
Let's go! Let's go!
Cool?
[kids laughing]
[Ukrainian]
All right, bye guys.
-No, nah.
-Happy birthday.
Is that what you were saying?
That guy's styling...
Yeah, bye guys.
Take care, ciao.
Starting to like it
out her in Borshchahovka
It's got, like, a small town feel to it
but it's in the city.
And it's funny that
in Troieshchyna they said,
"The dangerous part's Borshchahovka."
but in Borshchahovka they say,
"The dangerous part of the city
is in Troieshchyna."
Little rivalry going on.
But look at this park, I don't know
the name of it, but it's quite beautiful.
Tell you one place
it is dangerous in Kyiv...
Or one thing that is dangerous
to do in a city like this is...
Well, you're the foreign guy, or any guy,
and you wanna come in
and build a new apartment complex
or some new, big business operation.
Good luck with that.
You'll need your connections
and that's, I think
when you find yourself in a lot of danger
or in politics.
I think that's a dangerous place to be.
But as far as a tourist, not so much.
Really, I mean...
Gotta say, the thing about Ukraine,
is it's smack in the middle
between chaos and order.
It's in between India and Switzerland.
So you can find nice, civilized places.
Cafes, restaurants,
it's not all super crowded
but it's a little bit wild.
Like there are no, "No." signs.
There are no,
"Don't ride your bike
on the sidewalk." signs.
That sh*t does not exist here.
People park their cars on the sidewalks.
Whatever, can be annoying
but quite free in that respect.
What is it?
Monday in the park, people just chilling.
Drinking, eating...
I think it's a cool environment.
That's what's beautiful about this place.
Very, very...
-Picnic.
-Picnic, Picnic.
[streetcar passing]
Babushka deal going on over here.
Let's see what they're doing.
[women chattering]
[Peter giggles]
It's one of the big pluses here.
Look, you have a country...
[coughs]
You have a country technically at war.
You have a huge economic disparity.
There are very rich people,
the majority of people don't have much.
Usually when you have that imbalance
there's a lot of crime,
there's a lot of danger,
and you just don't feel it here.
I'm not gonna discredit...
You know, there's sh*t
that happens for sure.
There's crime, I'm not gonna be
this rose-colored glasses dude
and say nothing happens here.
Of course, of course things happen here.
But it's not at all like most people think
and it's a testament.
It's seriously a testament...
Oh, these guys... Oh sh*t.
You guys again?
Wednesday, YouTube, you guys.
[excited] Thank you.
[Ukrainian]
You wanna say anything?
-Come to Ukraine, we very cool,
and have a nice day.
-See you, guys.
-Thank you, man.
-Nice dance.
[Peter chuckling]
That's what I love about this country.
It's got that... It's got that tough look
but people are very warm.
Very real, very authentic.
Not for everyone.
If you want that, sort of,
slicked over, new, Dubai feeling,
then Kyiv, Ukraine is not your place.
There are very nice neighborhoods here.
There are very nice buildings
and newer stuff
but overall, it's not that place.
So that's the story, guys.
Thanks for coming along and...
[crows cawing]
Until next time...